well what are your thoughts about
um communism the 20th century
i apologize i'm reading the rise and
fall
third reich oh my god
so i'm like really steeped into like
world war
ii and stalin and
hitler and just these dramatic
personalities that brought so much evil
to the world
but it's also interesting to politically
think about
these different systems and what they've
led to
and uh russia is one of the sort of
beacons of communism in the 20th
century what are your thoughts about
communism having experienced it
as a political system i mean i have only
experienced it a little bit but mostly
through stories and through
you know seeing my parents my
grandparents who lived through that
it was horrible it was just plain
horrible
it was just awful um you think it's
there's something
i mean it sounds nice on paper
there's uh so like the drawbacks of
capitalism is that uh
you know eventually there is it's a it's
the point of like a slippery slope
eventually it creates uh
you know the rich get richer it creates
a disparity like inequality
of um wealth and equality if
like you know i guess it's hypothetical
at this point but
eventually capitalism leads to humongous
inequality and that that's you know some
people argue that that's
a source of unhappiness is it's not like
absolute wealth of people it's
the fact that there's a lot of people
much richer than you
there's a feeling of like that's where
unhappiness can come from so the idea of
of communism or these sort of marxism is
uh
is is not allowing that kind of slippery
slope
but then you see the actual
implementations of it and still seems to
be
seems to go wrong very badly
what do you think that is why does it go
wrong
what is it about human nature if we look
at chernobyl
you know those kinds of bureaucracies
that were constructed
is there something like do you think
about this much
of like why goes wrong well there's no
one was really like
it's not that everyone was equal
obviously the you know the
the government and everyone close to
that were
the bosses so it's not like fully i
guess
uh there's already this dream of equal
life so
then i guess the the situation that we
hadn't
you know the russia and soviet in the
soviet union it was more
it's a bunch of really poor people
without any way to
make any you know significant fortune or
build anything
living constant um under constant
surveillance
surveillance from other people like you
can't even you know
uh do anything that's not fully approved
by the
dictatorship basically otherwise your
neighbor will write
a letter and you'll go to jail absolute
absence of
actual law yeah this constant state of
fear
you didn't own any own anything it
didn't you know the
you couldn't go travel you couldn't read
anything
western or you could make a career
really unless you're working in the
uh military complex
which is why most of the scientists were
so well regarded i come from you know
both my dad my mom come from
families of scientists and they they
were really well regarded as you as you
know obviously because the state
wanted i mean because there's a lot of
value to them being well regarded
because they were developing things that
could be used in in the military
so that was very important that was the
main investment um
but was miserable it was so miserable
that's why you know a lot of russians
now live in the state of
constant ptsd that's why we you know
want to buy
buy buy and definitely if as soon as we
have the opportunity
you know we just got to it finally that
we can you know own things you know i
remember the time
that we got our first yogurts and that
was the biggest deal in the world
it was already in the 90s by the way
what was your like
favorite food what was like whoa like
this is possible
oh fruit because we only had apples
bananas
and whatever and you know whatever
watermelons whatever
you know people would grow in the soviet
union so there were no
pineapples or papaya or mango like
you've never seen those fruit things
like those were so
ridiculously good and obviously you
could not get any like strawberries in
winter
or anything that's not you know seasonal
um
so that was a really big deal seeing all
these fruit things yeah me too actually
i don't know i think i have a
like i don't think i have any too many
demons uh
or like addictions or so on but i think
i've developed an
unhealthy relationship with fruit that i
still struggle with
oh you can get any type of fruit right
you can get like also these weird fruit
fruits like dragon fruit or something
more all kinds of
like different types of peaches like
cherries were killer for me
i know i know you say like we had
bananas and so on but
i don't remember having the kind of
banana like when i first came to this
country
the amount of banana i like literally
got fat on bananas
like the amount oh yeah for sure
delicious and like cherries the kind
like just the quality of the food
i was like this is capitalism this is
that's pretty
it's delicious yeah yeah
yeah it's funny it's funny
yeah like it's it's funny to read
i don't know what to think of it of uh
it's funny to think how an idea
that's just written on paper one carried
out
amongst millions of people how that gets
actually
when it becomes reality what it actually
looks like
uh sorry but the
been studying hitler a lot recently and
uh
going through mineconf he uh pretty much
wrote out of minecon for everything he
was going to do
unfortunately most leaders including
stalin didn't read the
read it but it's it's kind of terrifying
and
i don't know and amazing in some sense
that you can have some words on paper
and they can be brought to life and they
can either inspire the world or they can
destroy the world
and uh yeah there's a lot of lessons
to study in history that i think people
don't study enough now i know one of the
things i'm
hoping with i'm practicing russian a
little bit i'm hoping to sort of
find rediscover the
the beauty and the terror of russian
history
through this stupid podcast
by talking to a few people so anyway i
just feel like so much was forgotten
i so much was forgotten i'll probably
i'm gonna try to
convince myself to um that you're super
busy and super important person well
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to befriend you
to uh
to try to become a better russian
because i feel like i'm a shitty russian
not that busy so i can totally be a
russian sherpa
you